these paintings and drawings are not the
work of a human at least not directly
but of a robot
one of the best known humans in the
realm of robot art is Patrick plays a he
has three robots working for him in his
London studio and they are all called
poor here they're getting ready for a
drawing session it's complicated because
for me there are machines you know my
rights programs there's ends if made my
career you know and there are also the
kind of self-portraits it's a complex
relationship between between yen's or
about but also for me laughter that said
we really do most of the time what I
want them to do what they do is scan a
room with their camera eyes and
recognize human faces then they draw
what they see including shadows it can
take up to 40 minutes today has a
master's in computer science he made and
programmed his robots himself even
though Sabina to pair has posed more
than 20 times for poor or Paul or Paul
she says it still feels weird the
machine is basically imitating human
behavior so you're kind of like familiar
with the movements but at the same time
not really because you are aware that is
not a pair of eyes that's a camera so
you know but then at the same time the
movements are so naturally done that
you're slightly confused that time many
who see the robots at work feel the same
way at least once a month they perform
in public this event was in Paris last
year as an artist and as a scientist
ties a is interested in the interaction
of human and machine people tend to
ascribe human attributes to the robots
as soon as thing as a behavior that make
sense so look at something and react you
have to understand then you react to it
it's animal
you just we can't help it robots doing
art is not new nor is computer science
examining art the British artist Harold
Cohen started developing his RN program
in the late 1960s it decides what to
draw or paint its output has been shown
in museums around the world other robots
respond to external influences this one
transformed sounds into impulses that
determine the movements of its painting
arm the e David painting robot is the
brainchild of scientists at the
University of Constance it imitates a
range of painting techniques and uses
them to depict new motifs the question
underlying the project is can machines
be taught to be creative if you want you
have a bird and a plane so they do the
same thing but not at all in the same
way so in this no matter if she
shouldn't agents can be like that for
example you would think that to do a
drawing like that you have to have some
intelligence or Sensibility but the
system is not specially intelligent
because at the moment is no intelligent
system it doesn't exist artificial
intelligence doesn't exist at each new
art robot seeks to be brainy and more
creative than the last pushing the
boundaries of artificial intelligence
trece is a visiting research fellow at
Goldsmiths College University of London
he has always been fascinated by both
art and technology after he sought
treatment for mental health problems he
discovered that he had lost his passion
for art for doing things by hand now
Paul the robot does it for him computing
no is used for everything so why not the
art I mean no of course there is this
kind of speciality but a lot of artists
use computers in one way or another to
do their work which is just a tool his
adjutant may be very adept and able and
he may have delegated plenty of work to
them
trece says he is still the artist I
think things are going to take about it
because you see rather a nut is behind
it there are people in the scientific
community of technologies community
while not artists to try to get system
to make out just doesn't work because
they don't have this knowledge of of
what is out it is very unlikely that
robots will soon be doing their own
thing as in creating their own art still
what they are already doing today is
fascinating and just a bit uncanny